it's a fool a Capcom exclusive yo is
power 98.3 man shouts of swag clothing
are we out here you already know man
check them out they throw on the show we
got yg in the build a bootleg cab so why
g400 is in this [__] you just dropped
this mixtape man well not you didn't
just drop it it's been out for a minute
no we're still making a lot of waves in
the street man just read up to yeah and
we were talking off-camera and I can't
you can't talk like I can talk but i'ma
say man def jam is thoroughly [__] up
your [__] bro you broke is that [__]
right now that's that soon now let me
ask you a question like you've had so
many street hits club hits what is
holding back yg from being like that
that superstar that didn't go to New
York and go to Miami you know I mean lau
la west coast you good what do you think
is the big thing that's holding you back
from from transcending across the
country across the world for them and
I mean of course you got fans across the
world but you feel you know what I'm
saying yeah is this is Tommy
and it's the politics you got to play
with the label [__] they love the games
you got to go through and the politics
you gotta [__] with the right people and
all that so you fill me right now I'm
[__] with the right people so it's
going to be it's finna go while hopping
finna come out you're familiar pushing
fill me and everything is going to be
everything it ain't gonna be no more
sleeping on old records it's not a lot
of sleeping going on bro it's a lot of
sleeping sleep on me that's how you eat
got by Freddy Krueger [__] you
feel me I like jeezy on my team now you
feel me so he he got the label going
hard for me and Jeezy supposed to
executive-produce album right yeah and
I'm corporate thuggin though people
don't know that you're officially
corporate tte here we link that we
partnered up yg CTE reppin you know what
it is man that bo honey game you already
know pushing pushing to label everything
fold on it corporate dougie so Stacy
pushing Inc YG is officially that's
that's the that's the that's the link
right there I said exclusive right here
uh yeah me and Jeezy parted up though
the album's finna come out my [__] he
going hard for me to name it album I'm
from Bob see you already know he's also
so be on the lookout for that I'm from
bompton the album all right so i need to
know brother like like you said you and
Jeezy are real close Jeezy is one of the
big dogs at Def Jam how did you guys
link up being from each from Atlanta you
from from LA from Compton your I'm
saying how did that happen he was in the
city of gonna clubs and [__] I was in
the club the same night he's a drummer
was DJing who was in LA it was cracking
drama start paying all my [__] he said I
said cracking Eli oh [__] so he started
making cars to the labor late I'm sorry
[__] was she so we made up and I was
like a year ago
minute you think I was a year ago we've
been [__] with each other for years
he's building in court records talking
about what we're gonna do all that all
right so mustard your boy you guys are
like partners that's your AJ that's the
dude who makes the majority of your
beats on top you guys have kind of
crafted this sound man that's that's hot
like I I think when people think of this
is this West Coast sound they
automatically think DJ mustard that's
the first name they're gonna think of
right on top so hey how did you a
mustard get together like where did you
guys link up in life like how long have
you been rocking with each other how'd
you guys meet how'd you guys start
working with each other we met like I'm
a [__] muscle like 45 years before he
was uh making beats he was DJing my
homie of law was [__] with and I lay
on some management [__] Big B he linked
me with i a mushroom okay and mustards
did my first mixed to high dollar sign
right other summer muscles in my first
week stay put it out ever since then
keeping my DJ ever since then he's
starting to roc nation oh he good he
getting all type of placement singles on
everybody stick roc nation managing it
he doing and [__] that's my whole thing
is with this sound that everyone's
taking advantage of say two Chainz say
Jeezy we'll all righty Ludacris just
dropped a muster joint today
these songs are getting national
attention I getting played in New York
on New York radio and [__] but it's
almost like it's your sound like do you
ever get frustrated with that like
you're not saying I get a little
frustrated but I'm over that [__]
because it's right its timing about him
using the sound with the singles and all
that [__] they played it on a radio in
New York it's helping my [__] because
when my [__] come out coming they
already gonna be familiar with the sound
but it's probably gonna be YG family
they're not too familiar with me in
there Marcus right the sound is gonna be
already familiar the sound is what it is
then they go know after day to hear my
sitting like my scene and they do that
homework you feel they don't know that's
my [__] that's me a must machine see
what mustard me like there's other dudes
in the city like problems to understand
you got two dudes like tile of course
Tigers doing this thing um and I feel
like everyone's sound is kind of I want
to say on the same tip of course
problems [__] with legal stars you
know I'm saying and muster for that
matter I mean no mustard [__] problem
but um who I mean who started this
[__] this Cali [__] cuz this it's a
lot of people who are doing their thing
right now we're using it you don't have
said real real I real a real recognize
real money that's all i'll [__] what
everybody though not everybody not
everybody not everybody that's my thing
is LA has always been known to kind of
be divided cuz la there's always that
his [__] his hoes I was here [__] do
whole [__] [__] his hoes filmy biggest
haters and all that for me that's why
but that's what it is that's going on
everywhere at all you feel me ice
everywhere right right so uh I'm for
bumped in the album yes we've been
waiting this out man to turn em but it
was huge that was almost three years ago
almost [__] was cool that was cool but
it was a big wreck
right was a big way I'm saying when we
gonna get this yg I'm when we get weak
on the soul the an additional top is you
got some crazy features in the can I got
crazy records I off-speed super her
chair I heard you got everybody on your
[__] I got everybody on my I have you
got almost everybody on your [__] a lot
everybody that's important everybody
losing more partners on the [__] out
not everybody is selling records on my
seat everybody selling records is I'm
not even gonna say everybody I'm gonna
say I got somebody that's selling
records on my seat that's for something
that's the Sun why jelly he's selling
more regulars in more than half of these
[__] okay can you tell us who's on the
album no no God do your homework who's
selling records right now is only like
five people y'all got it y'all got to
stay tuned we ll be looking for that why
did you find my suit we're gonna do
another mixtape before the Alma we just
go next book know what's gonna make an
album [__] Mick said we want Santa
album it's dudes dropped it I mean
albums worth of mixtapes like I'm gonna
join a lot of free [__] I begin slept on
I'm tired of it [__] time to wake him up
I put my foot down [__] hey I
gotta I gotta tell you I have a hard
time playing I'm from bombed in the club
I'm afraid of some Crips are gonna kill
me then gonna kill you they gotta
respect I play out from Balkans and
every time I gotta watch the dudes I
went snooping in was doing a [__] and it
was big trippin everybody was loving it
but I was loving me everybody was loving
what is your position respect and be
nice if they talking about his real [__]
so I I come talking about my so upset
but my bartending all that don't hate on
it just respect it it is what it is
respecting my what's your favorite right
your personal favorite record of yours
to hear in the club [__] you
broken out from bouncing in my two
favorite records every off the same take
two of the same tape and I lied to you
and I'm a third to all of us it there it
is man yg in the building get the new
album whenever it comes out here who
like calves why'd you you already know
man will they care but don't bootleg
Marcy I don't believe I don't believe no
I'm not talking I'm not talking about
talking everybody else out there go cop
that [__] why
man let's go holes